A gross question warning, should a severely itchy rectum in surrounding skin be good,
severely itchy rectum in started skin be reacted to the coffee acid other in a coffee
animal.
I do them daily.
I do, I do have a latex allergy.
I call a premiere coffee animal product animal itself asking if there's latex and
they said, no, however, there's something else in their attachments that sounded questionable,
but I can't think of what it was.
Or could it be parasites?
I've been taking advantage of this all for a while or hemorrhoids.
Typically a severe itchy rectum is not good.
Well, it could be hemorrhoids probably not though.
And if it's a healthy skin, it's more like a reaction to something.
It certainly could be a reaction to the coffee.
Yeah, I would maybe just give it a break for a bit.
Use some olive oil or coconut oil on your bottom and let that heal.
Just I would give it a break.
I don't know what you could be reacted to.
It certainly could be something in the plastic could be the coffee.
I couldn't be parasites.
I maybe.
The only way to know parasites.
I mean, technically, we learned how to look for parasites.
It's really itchy rectums.
You have to put a piece taped out on your bottom and pull it off.
Ouch.
And then take that and put it under a microscope and look and see if there's eggs that are coming out.
But I would just honestly just give it a break for a bit.
And then take that and put it under a microscope.